معنى من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس
الحديث الان اييه حول
اجتماع الكبنت الامني الاسرائيلي هذا
الاجتماع الذي نقل من مقر وزاره الدفاع
الى ااا مقر الشباب تحسبا للتظاهرات
الاسبوعيه ضد حكومه نتنياهو لكن يبدو من
خلفك كما نشاهد في الصور ان المعارضه
الاسرائيليه تستعد فعلا لهذه التظاهرات
همم الليليه ضعنا في سوره الاجواء وما
يمكن ان يطرح في هذا الاجتماع ويقر
بالفعل حسن
وعمليه هذه المظاهرات للمعارضه بقيت على
حالها رغم بعض الاصوات التي تعالت على
الاقل في الساعات الاخيره الى الغائها في
عقاب العمليه التي شهدتها مدينه القدس
ليله امس بالتحديد لكن منظمو هذه
المظاهرات رفضوا ذلك وهم مصممون على
اقامتها هنا في وسط لابيب وكذلك في منطقه
قريبه من وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه
التوقعات بان يكون هنالك عشرات الاف
الاسرائيليين الذين سيخرجون هذا اليوم
للتضاور الاسبوع الماضي بلغ عدد المشاركين
نحو 130,000 اسرائيلي سواء كان هنا في تل
ابيب وفي حيفا وفي القدس والتوقعات بان
هذه الاعداد سوف تكون ربما اكبر هذا اليوم
هذا سنراه في غضون الساعات القليله
المقبله لكن كما ذكرت حسن الانظار تبقى
متجهه حقيقه نحو ما سيخرج عن اجتماعي
المجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون السياسيه
والامنيه في اسرائيل ومن الواضح بان هذا
المجلس سوف يتخذ سلسله من القرارات المهمه
في قادم الساعات سوف يعلن عليها بطبيعه
الحال لكن نبقى في اطار التقديرات
والتوقعات لما يمكن لهذه الحكومه اليمنيه
ولهذا المجلس ان يتخذه من قرارات واضح
تماما بان
النقطه الاولى والانطلاقه الاولى لهذه
القرارات تتمثل في تعزيز القوى الامنيه
سواء كان ذلك في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
وبالجديد على مدينه القدس بالتحديد
ناسيهما وان القدس تعتبر الان بالنسبه
للحكومه الاسرائيليه عقب اخيل بمعنى هي
النقطه الضعف الاكبر بنسبه لاسرائيل ذلك
ان الفلسطينيون الموجودون في مدينه القدس
بامكانهم ان يتنقل ما بين الضفه الغربيه
وما بين القدس وبالتالي بامكانهم ان
ينقلوا السلاح وبامكانههم ان ينفذوا
عمليات ضد اهداف الاسرائيليه وبالتالي
بيسبب ذلك نحن سنرى كما يبدو قرارات تتعلق
بتجديد الاجراءات الامنيه على الحواجز
المؤديه تحديدا بين الضفه الغربيه والقدس
من ناحيه وربما ايضا وضع حواجز جديده او
دوريات عسكريه بين الاحياء الفلسطينيه في
القدس المحتله والمناطق الغربيه او الجهه
الغربيه لمدينه القدس تجديد الاجراءات
الامنيه تجديد التفتيش وان كانت هذه
الاجراءات ربما
تكون قادره على منع هذه العمليات 100% ذلك
انه لا يوجد هنالك اي ارضيه لعمل منظم ااه
تقف من ورائه الفصائل الفلسطينيه انما كما
يقول الاسرائيليون يتحدثون عن ذئاب منفرده
يخططون ويقررون المكان والزمان لتفيد هذه
العمليه
المحتله نتوقع ان تكون هنالك الدفع بمزيد
من همم وحدات القتاليه الى
الضفه الغربيه المحتله وربما عمل على
تقطيعه اوصالها بمزيد من الحواجز في
محاوله لمحاصره المقاتلين الفلسطينيين
تحديدا في منطقتين نابلس
شكرا لك من تل ابيب مراسله جزيره الياس
كرم